remember the press here to see level two
papi Parnell is an investigative
journalist whose career was made on a
very high-profile case open to him
through her writing she had a boy from a
very affluent neighborhood tried as an
adult
16 year old Warren cave was taken into
custody he was ultimately found guilty
of murdering his neighbor and 19 years
later she has to face whether or not she
helped to send an innocent man to prison
when papi comes to Warren's rescue he is
apprehensive and definitely has his
guard up why are you even here I think I
can help you this time
papi is a podcaster and she's a media
celebrity who has all the trappings of
success and came from very humble
beginnings she finds out that there was
a case she was involved with years ago
and the new evidence has come forward
the case against Warren was largely
circumstantial police did not have a
witness to the actual attack and Chuck's
life Aaron along with twin daughters
Josie and Laney had slept through the
slaughter
I played twins Josie and Lanie whose
father was killed
the twins are kind of locked in this
eternal dynamic with one another and
completely overwhelmed and often trapped
by familial constructions of the past
everybody's lives stopped in one way or
the other the night
murder you know how every few years of
vulture comes out of the woodwork and
starts asking about my dad what now
Bobby Parnell is somebody who just wants
to find the truth she's jumping
wholeheartedly into it without really
understanding all the facts and she
creates a great deal of turmoil and pain
this part now I'm asking you to stop I
can't do that
there's podcast unearths all of these
different things and causes people to
reckon with a lot of stuff that they
maybe haven't resolved from their past
poppy has created a lot of problems stop
talking to that woman
she has to ask herself at every turn am
i doing this for the right reasons am I
just trying to find the truth so badly
it destroys everybody else your eyes are
way off the main goal here I'm just
going after the truth but we're playing
with people's lives here pal are you
ready for the consequences it was
important for her to go against
everything I mean everything to get to
the truth
[Music]
you think all the secrets came out
during the trial
you